we've been hearing about antitrust and
monopoly and
you know we got to break up facebook
they're too big too big to fail the
banks are too big everything that we've
heard for years with wall street
yesterday was pretty damn evident like
ironically twitter hello world yeah
because you had basically one source of
all right here's where you go to tell
your story when facebook owns facebook
instagram oh by the way shout out to
michael berry's uh option call on
facebook
it just puts things in perspective like
damn do we need to break up facebook
does are they getting too big are they
getting too clearly that is a great
question what do you think about that
that's something that we need to talk
about and then part b to that as i've
also heard
well the the the whistleblower what was
her name again francis
hagin she had some pretty compelling
stuff if you haven't seen that interview
so someone said well yeah that you know
her interview the whistleblower
basically saying that facebook was sort
of like amplifying
stuff that was more divisive
controversial topics and it would push
it to the top of the algorithm and and
get you know that's that's how you would
make your ad money because it's so
engaging and all that stuff and they
said then because of her interview and
the whistleblowing
that they wanted to do something to draw
less attention away from her interview
and i said
i don't know about this a buddy of mine
i was like i don't know about that man
because i got to be honest with you i
was just kind of living my own life on
sunday watching uh tom brady do his
thing i didn't see the interview i
didn't hear about the interview
ironically so now
all i'm hearing about is the interview
because facebook went down
so why would they want to
plus the interview was to me like a big
nothing burger it was just 60 minutes or
whatever it wasn't that big it was a big
deal but not that big of a deal but now
all your platforms are going down for
six hours the whole world is now talking
about facebook that doesn't make sense
to me that would be sort of
counterproductive
if i were to go that route with your
buddy the pandora papers make more sense
to me pandora papers make way more sense
vladimir putin goes shut it down you
know like i don't the world doesn't need
to know about this so just shut it all
down do we think what so what are the
top three
reasons for this you're saying that it
was a hack china something like that a
data breach
facebook shut it down intentionally it
was just an accident i don't think this
doesn't seem coincidental what do you
think do i think this was an accident
like accidentally this happened no i
don't think this is an accident do i
think we know for a fact what happened
no do i think facebook knows what
happened absolutely do i think facebook
will reveal to the world what really
happened zero chance so you know
everything else is until somebody on the
inside decides to come out and be the
next whistleblower to say what really
happened to facebook everything's gonna
be speculation
my seat yeah this seat is warm for you
come sit down anybody from facebook
twitter please you know you you are
going to do
you're going to be remembered all right
for what you do in this world if you sit
there and do nothing again we talked
about it if you allow
if you do nothing all right that's all
evil needs to win all right come out and
and use the platform speak your truth
let the world know let me ask you a
question let me ask you a question do
you think the world's a better place
without facebook like you you're saying
like
ousting facebook and being gone do you
think well no go back to what adam said
before because that was a very good
question do you think facebook as it
currently exists is a good thing do you
think it should be broken up
well to me it's not about whether it's
broken up or not i i don't if if the
answer to the question is mark didn't
know yeah you need you need seven ceos
running companies
if mark didn't know that this stuff is
taking place yeah you need you need more
leadership to to do what they're doing
no question about it because it's too
big yeah because if that if that's the
case but if mark no so let's just say we
talked to mark mark did you know about
this i did not know about this no
problem you need to be broken up
you need more leadership how do you not
know about this how important is this
matt if this is true how important is it
to you mark very it is yeah so don't you
think as a ceo of the company you need
to be aware of something that's very
important to you yes so how do who who
screwed up here who needs to get fired
who didn't do their job
is there enough investment being made in
people to watch over this maybe right
now you're only putting one percent of
the company's revenue and total profits
into it maybe you need to increase that
to three percent if it's really
important
maybe the amount of control needs to be
internal maybe they're so that's the
conversation i'm having that's purely a
business conversation for me if mark
didn't know but let's circle back to
what what you talked about earlier with
you know them being able to turn off
content and being able to shadow band
mark zuckerberg is not making that call
mark's not looking at what do you think
where's cheryl sandberg and all this and
what's the what's the screening process
for the people that you know with their
finger on the boat let me ask you a
question so you've got to be very
careful when you're going there by the
way
you got to be very careful if you're
going
people have to be very careful
complaining about that let me explain
because if we go in that route
complaining about that a little bit too
much who's the only other person that is
going to control that button i don't
think there should be a button
no no wait there needs to be a button
let me explain why there needs to be a
button the whole purpose of this guy if
there's no button those videos will be
live public to everybody yeah no so
there no that's that's that's not that's
not something you need bro let me put it
to you this way first time you saw
again we talked about this before first
time you saw extreme porn what did it do
to you how old were you like it messes
with a kid when you see that you're like
what the hell is this like you know how
they say smoking weed is is is okay if
you try it after 30 years old if you
smoke weed too early it's not good you
do you it's too early for you to start
your kids watching uh uh
faces of death
yeah that that's a great example like
that's a great example [ __ ] was you know
i remember being like what 10 12 years
old like oh man like
you're seeing faces of death we're like
what's that and then you see someone
getting shot i think some of that yeah
yeah
i don't think that's stuff
sure what about that movie with nicholas
cage six millimeter do you remember them
yeah whatever the hell it was yeah snuff
film sure but if we're if we're just if
we're just talking about that binary if
we're talking about the binary extreme
of too much censorship or too little
censorship give me too little all the
time every single time and that person
who's posting that snuff
all right everybody in the world will
know who it is and we can point the
finger at them and we can say that's who
it is that's the background okay that's
the bad guy
that was my point earlier
i learned about the broken windows
theory from rudy giuliani from our
conversation with rudy giuliani it is a
remarkably small amount of people in the
world that are committing heinous crimes
and all you have to do is find that
small the the
you're saying do be the cop of those bad
guys no what i'm saying is is that
putting them in the shadows doesn't make
the snuff go away it just makes it be in
the shadows so
censoring other people under the guise
of somehow protecting the innocent is to
me a horrible slippery slope i you don't
protect the innocent by silencing people
that that haven't done anything wrong
and you don't give
you don't know this operative's power
okay i gotta be honest i i i i tend to
agree with gerard on this yeah do you
have like a level setting
you know what i mean like
a certain setting they're saying like
yeah i want to see explicit content and
therefore like people can
you know okay well i want to see this
face of the day i want to see this stuff
well that's just what they have on the
movies you know but with you pg-13
societies whatever what i think what
what the the moderator was saying more
than anything else is what these people
were doing was remarkably illegal this
was incest this was um um uh pedophilia
this was bestiality these things are in
fact illegal why isn't the company that
he works for
because you know we already said like
reporting report that to the authority
and because they know what he said he
says why he was blowing he said these
people are such idiots they left their
license plate on there he says in many
cases they left the streets where they
lived on like you could go find these
guys like they're they're idiots he
could be a digital vigilante and say you
know what i'm gonna i'm gonna create
this company i would guarantee you i
would bet you anything that this guy has
fantasized about being batman he knows
who these people are and going and yeah
he needs to be protected to your point
like seriously you gotta you gotta
expose the shadows with the sunlight you
gave that reference yeah these people
are gonna be doing some wild [ __ ]
regardless yes and if they're they're
that foolish and that's sloppy to
show their home address or show their
license plate and they do it on facebook
or facebook live and they get caught
i'd rather them get caught than just
continue to do that you're saying leave
a hundred percent of stuff on i'm not
saying a hundred percent i'm definitely
not saying a hundred percent
but these people are going to be doing
illegal weird crazy psychopathic stuff
regardless i'm not advocating for i'd
like to catch them i'm not advocating i
think we're all on the same page pat
was he afraid of his well-being
no
i don't think so at all really no oh i
would be scared [ __ ] yeah i'd be like
but but this is a guy that's got he's
not somebody that's married he's a guy
that's like listen i'm just i'm just
doing this because i want this stuff to
stop so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
[Music]
you